it's great to be here the World Economic
Forum certainly with a group of the
Schwab social entrepreneurs and I think
probably the biggest untapped resource
by America is the human potential that
exists there are people who are
obviously some within the cycle of
poverty which is extremely difficult to
escape and it's very important that
there are social innovations they're
implemented by organizations governments
and businesses to support people but if
we really want to tap the potential the
key is going to come from the
communiqués themselves and so it's about
how to rheas organizations and
businesses and governments allows
support community so that they can
realize how to utilize their own assets
that they have how they can come with
their own social innovations because
that's really where cling to a scale so
the important part moving forward needs
to plant the seed so that social
innovation can grow from communities and
then and then tap into further and
further communities in the region so
that homegrown solutions can be can be
innovative in clinical scales